It turns out that any monomial that we encounter will be an example of a
polynomial. Monomials have one term, and are the products of constant
coefficients and variables. Binomials are another type of polynomial. These
contain exactly two terms. A trinomial is another example of a polynomial. This
one has three terms. I've been throwing this word term around a lot. And a term
is simply the product of numbers and variables. This is one term. This is one
term. And this is one term. The same is true for these. When we have addition or
subtraction between two terms, that's when we call it a binomial. And the same
is true in this case. We call this a trinomial. You can remember these terms
based on their prefix. Mono means one. Bi means two. And tri means three. That
should be pretty familiar. A bicycle has two wheels. A triangle has three sides.
Maybe you can think of some other words that start with these prefixes.